are with the questions from America
senator McCaskill what was your
reasoning behind supporting the Iran
deal
oh that's news today yesterday yesterday
good for you it was a no-brainer yeah
well you know I called the countries
that are part of the deal more
importantly I call the countries that
are holding Iran's money everybody
thinks that we control this money we
don't it's in South Korea Japan China
India yeah oh I call those country lot
in Westwood and ask them hey are you
going to respect unilateral sanctions in
the United States if we walk away from
this deal and I got an uneasy feeling
that this sanction regime was gonna fray
if we don't do this deal which means
they could get the 60 billion without
cement down there centrifuges know now
that would be a bad outcome right that
would be a bad outcome that's why it was
a no brainer
Marc Maron did sitting down with
President Obama in such a casual setting
change how you viewed him yeah yeah he's
just a guy
no it was it was pretty astounding I was
very nervous to have been weird when the
president comes to your house and right
because you do your podcast for me I
have a two bedroom house with one
bathroom and the door my bathroom
doesn't even work and we do it in the
garage right and I had to I literally
had to ask my neighbor I said you know
Dennis would it be okay if we put
snipers on the roof and he's retired
through his like yeah you [ __ ]
kidding me that's terrific but it was
pretty fascinating because I was nervous
because as you know you talk to to some
politicians you want to get past that
they're talking points and have that
experience and very quickly I I he put
me at easy he walked into the garage he
looked around there's a lot of artwork
that my fans send of me and he
immediately said why you're pretty
narcissistic so there was a moment where
he would really grounded himself in the
environment it was very connected and I
felt I had I had a lot of respect for
him as a person because I felt like I
was able to talk to the person he's a
very thoughtful it was a terrific gonna
be oh thank you very much you thanks a
lot
Donna Edwards what differentiates you
from your opponent in the upcoming
Senate race Wow such a good softball
question I actually there are a lot of
things that differentiate us I mean
first of all it goes without saying I'm
an african-american woman running for
the United States Senate when there
hasn't been one what was the last one
carol moseley-braun under four years ago
one in our 239 year history and I think
I bring a perspective to the Senate that
will be different and that will be added
to the voices of the women in the Senate
and on some public policy issues know we
talked earlier we talked about Social
Security and I have been a very strong
component of strengthening expanding
Social Security and Medicare their
earned benefits that we pay into and
unfortunately my opponent has said in a
number of occasions that he would
consider cutting Social Security and
Medicare and I wouldn't do that right
and you know a lot of that money of
course is used to put old people at
homes and I know in your book you say
that's something that the people who
live a long life just they don't even
know what that was to put parents in a
shame the family it would shame the
family yeah yeah you and I'm sorry did I
open that with a question is your
thoughts day
ask me the question again well I was
just gonna I read in your book that the
people in the Blue Zones right they do
not know this concept that we have in
America yeah beige homes where people go
visit their parents once a week and and
it's just a different way of looking at
things and why does that contribute to
living so long well it's more if you put
your aging parent in retirement home
it'll shave between two and six years
off of their life expectancy I think
part of it is that if if your aging
parents in the home there's two in Blue
Zones anyway they're continuing to help
cook help take care of kids run the
garden they're not only feeling a sense
of purpose or a sense of responsibility
they have a reason to get up in the
morning they have a reason to stay
active a reason to take their meds and
when you put people in a retirement home
it's like well they wake up well what I
do today you know go play shuffleboard
so it's a it's an important idea I thank
dear maybe they wouldn't need beds not
certainly not as much you know you in
none of these really have meds in these
places they all have good public health
systems Costa Rica for example your
Europe have these viagra pills that we
were talking about haha is that
something they need or do they have well
naturally rection well I think he said
public health systems did that's right
yes I said public's was specific make
sure I heard that yes so
this is interesting in Costa Rica a
fifty-year-old is about three times more
likely to reach a healthy age 90 than an
American is and they spend 115 the
amount we do on health care but it's
almost all on public health in every
little village they have a plus with a
salud where what's that damn where where
a pregnant mother is taught how to feed
their child they kids get vaccinations
and makes a big difference okay all
right well speaking of that will the GOP
admit that Obamacare is working or will
they continue to campaign on its demise
good question
maybe that's for you Charles well that's
it there's no numbers in that I could
give you some that's that's a very big
topic I think there have been certainly
some gains in terms of the uninsurance
rate going down having said that a lot
of it is Medicaid which is less than
ideal a lot of it is what has
essentially become high deductible plans
the wrong way round
you know conservatives want high
deductible plans that don't cover
quotidian everyone's everyday things
Oh clarity yeah I know qu ot hi dia but
there will be there if there's a if
there's a serious problem what we have
is the opposite at the moment and that's
largely because it's so prescriptive I
mean there's a federal regulator and
Aetna tells you what you need and you
know there was an interesting piece in
Harper's Magazine it didn't come from my
perspective but saying that I read it in
in combination with the Cadillac tax
which is probably more of a sort of you
know Toyota Corolla tax it's not really
just a top of the market like this is is
going to cause people a lot of problem
so this is a very complicated topic but
my question for the presidential
candidates the Republican presidential
candidates has anyone seen replace have
you ever seen it because I've been
hearing about replace for about six
years I got the bloodhounds out I don't
know if you have Donna in Washington
I've gone up and down the halls I've
searched an hearing room and
can't find replace our there is no
legislation there is no debate of
anything it's repeal and replaced but
when you ask them what replaces it is
crooked so I'm I'm actually not sure
I've not seen the legislation I've been
there the whole time with respect
senator I think you may need better
bloodhounds because this week Marco
Rubio purged as a plan this week Scott
Walker put out a flat if you go to where
Obama was when he was elected there was
no published plan at the point at which
there was a Democratic Congress in a
Democratic president the party picked up
what was essentially Clinton care but
with a few changes and then it ran with
it
you have the Coburn plan you have a
prize plan there's a lot of plans out
there I haven't coalesced around one you
know why because they haven't won the
president's and I just know that we have
the Republicans in charge of Congress I
know they have voted thousands of times
to repeal Obamacare I have never had an
opportunity on any piece of legislation
to replace it I'm not very charged with
oh don't tell me that it's there
somewhere and we just don't know it they
have not put it
I I think that the point is asked with
when Obama became president and he
didn't pick up the Bush platinum there
was a George W Bush health care plan in
2006 that went nowhere because there was
a Democratic Congress when you have
divided government there is not going to
be a big change to the health care
system Republicans know that and if
there's a unified government in 2016
which seems unlikely but if there is
then you're going to see maybe the Rubio
plan maybe the Walker plan maybe the
Coburn but one of those will be picked
up as it was with a bomber i think it's
an unfair criticism yeah let's hear it
for Charles for standing gets all of her
you